hey guys welcome back to the drunk
minecraft me waiter
Marc damn we're invincible Latin word Oh
go team go team we need to check out of
this Oh team go okay apparently I'm
sorry I'm sorry go team go team go team
go team ow
ah so Bob what we need to do is Wade
sucks donkey dick and is incapable of
playing well so we aim our guns over on
the Blue Square over there and then we
oh hi Wade oh hi mark
you look hungry okay really funny is
it's hard to do that and well I laugh in
real life I stop moving my head and I
move my character's head you just need
water and stuff to make oh god flatten
it so you're gonna get soggy an example
of all of this no no I have an idea but
what's the objective we don't have
anything to blow up we're building a
house and blowing up each other's houses
oh okay I didn't know that I don't know
we need well T and T for 1 and then
suckers and I are you know how to do
this how why do you know I don't I'm so
good second I'm just talking smack man
calm down okay all right I was you're on
my team so I don't know why I'm worried
oh my god I'll get to see an example or
are we just gonna take our water and our
bucket and our would see what happens I
think we should just start building me
what happened I have an idea I don't
know oh my god here we go
I don't know okay oh all right
I'm self-destructing panting oops
alright I'm gonna go with version one of
my can here I think I've got the winner
oh no I'm promotion for this area come
on work at all this I love my house this
supple game turned complicate
I got the winner right here to see you
guys wait and see
it's me to blow up my entire house it's
made of wood why is it made of wood and
now my floor is gone oh man whatever
zombies helping me right now
zombie aren't you helping me all right
fine I'll build it myself
zombie we're teammates not now now now
shut up I was on my side I don't have
enough wool for this zombie cuz I blew
it up Wow everyone everyone hang on to
your hats work out very well ah I have
an idea these these cannons don't launch
they do what we're doing huh zombies
building like a whole [ __ ] fortress
and audience haha whatever he's got two
people on his team
we're on our own just we're living life
hey guys I'm basically on my own let's
be honest here yeah whatever
Oh fire there's no point in having a
block of 64 buckets of water cuz it just
turns into one can't even break it down
Oh Bob you broke my buttons yeah okay
wait I got I got I got I got you split
the bucket yeah I got it and then just
lay them out I got it
Oh God nah water oh my water broke okay
I thought we were gonna have some team
working cooperation Bob did not know
that's not like us mark yes we can Anna
zombie my cannon shoots water haha how
you load it with water then by the way I
went to a Korean spa yesterday here in
LA it was awesome cuz it was happy
ending oh no I was there with a game
room so I don't assume there was anyone
got a happy ending
possum everyone did but you know I
missed out damn it anyway
everyone was naked haha zombie I'm
abandoning my fort moving in
uh wiser teen what why
ow nevermind to get your house it sucks
it hurts okay well that's wrong appeared
out
well clot Latins getting a great kick
out of this huh I almost died from
visiting my own Ally
no one cares Wade or not no one cares I
wonder if this'll work
hey Mark can you stand still for a
minute no why yes maybe just don't turn
around
okay and what uh hang on
I gotta put that back and then I got it
okay goodnight
this is the most technically okay that's
the advanced episode over here okay
alright
oh I'm watching over there wow yeah take
that Mark's house oh we're good half an
hour or are you guys want to see my
attempt at a cannon yes it's complicated
check this out
does it shoot a tree it shoots all three
it's like a shotgun cannon I like it Oh
you know it didn't actually damage my I
have to light it and run away but it's
gonna work okay okay okay I died Oh
Mark's dead
alright here it goes where's my
everything's obsidian all right let me
see what zombies got going on here
yeah this and gum and wide ha ha ha
damn it damn it damn it this house sucks
the work it's supposed to do ok Samus
doesn't work either I'm just saying just
happens to be Jillian I was standing on
top of the cannon watching and I got
killed
ha ha you see we just can't be in close
proximity to anything happening here
alright I've got I've got a new plan new
plan coming into effect here this one is
even more stunningly brilliant than the
last
I'm excited aside from lighting my wine
no way
[ __ ] oh yeah kidding me I got ya
how'd you figure this out yeah I'll take
that
all right ready wait it's gonna come
right at your face here okay whoa there
by market didn't work
hey whoa just gonna just gonna just
gonna make some explosions yeah yeah
damn it to hell all right ah blue house
ha ha ha
money you got what do you got working
over here wait what are your bomb you
don't know I've got something I've
actually got something that's working
how did your so how did yours work I
want to see this need to improve the
design of it it needs to be a bit more
robust doesn't finally destroy itself as
I'm fire always like not only slightly
onlys like uh well how do you load it
though how does this I'll show you I'll
show you I'll show you okay it's works
off of the principle that TNT can push
other TNT well yeah that's all cannons
work in Minecraft isn't it yeah I think
so so what I did was I do this wood and
then I took my water yes there we go and
then you light the back one I like the
back one and then I wait the other one
like hell oh god I'm a fire put it up
put it on you I made a slight
miscalculation oh [ __ ] oh god oh god oh
god you five is hilarious okay I don't
feel so bad anymore had one shoot right
at way we felt the impressiveness of my
campaign by X it doesn't gallery gotta
watch this watch those oh my god I'm
gonna throw up now huh okay
are we obvious coming Wang no way Oh
I can't believe that just happened were
I told you it works you didn't believe
me it works okay well so so far what
we've learned in this episode is that so
how mark is a genius everyone else
zombie and Latin howdy
no no wait come on don't be bitter about
it don't be a bitter bitter don't be a
bitter bitter ttan come on prove it your
design you were proving it by putting
TNT around the outskirts I mean kind of
use your design on your substance mark
I'm gonna use your design and I'm gonna
see if I can keep keep it going and
expand upon your idea I need what I need
both look it's a god zombie what does
I'll be don't overly need what I need is
I need a redstone line and I'll be I'm
getting assaulted on two fronts over
here while you're making a fortress can
you try to attack please I can make
multiple channels and I can make a
redstone line then it can be like a
total shotgun just like boom everything
goes out at once
I can't believe mark is the first one I
figured it out that's mark your
figure-eight ping our engineer of course
I can figure it out I'm smart oh I'm
supposed to be honest though that's only
half true Oh what do you mean is only
half true I'm smart I think that's a
falsity I think Wade sounds really
really better because he lost to mark
the fire sounds about right
what you feel better if mark was the one
that beat you to mean I'm gonna beim
what is this all this criticisms on my
behalf I like this it's a bitter melons
way damn yeah there's some assumptions
going on here way down I think you need
to address some issues
you got some like issues some issues
from latent issues yours ladies issues
no that's okay
okay zombie whoa oh you blew a big
[ __ ] hole in my [ __ ] all director can
in his way soon enough as soon as I
figure out this how the hell this works
I think I know I think I've got a better
solution for this I think I'm in trouble
mark I think zombie is for
about a functional cannon and it's just
gonna kill me forever
well I I've got a functional cannon kind
of yeah but it's not aimed at him and it
takes like a lifetime so feel it
oh okay alright whatever you don't want
faith in me no one has faith in me and
this goddamn episode up okay it's a fact
of life mark you have to rebuild your
whole cannon to aim it oh no no I just
have to build another cannon not rebuild
we fighting you at all who were you
trying to hit me don't worry about it
that's not working I don't want to tell
you no sabe don't do that
[ __ ] scumbag I'm never gonna be able
to do anything now zombies Broncos aam
be way to be a poor sport in the game
where we're supposed to be shooting each
other with cannons hey I'm just saying
he was the one didn't work at all yes uh
yes
what spoke to know how to do this anyway
anywhere yeah yeah anyway yeah but
really if you think about it mmm think
about think think about it alright so
I've got a trench
Wow I killed myself
well bad do that sounds like you earned
it yeah loser I'm the lovable goof ooh
all right I'm gonna go over light for a
test fire here before latin goddess
shoots me again and [ __ ] my [ __ ] up Bob
don't you aim that over here Oh
so come on so close Oh fair over there
I'm Ann and Bob I'll get your back as
soon as give me like five more minutes
I'll be up and operational just fire
back don't worry don't you worry buddy I
got your back yeah they broke me again
didn't it well I'm just gonna come and
help mark them yeah do that
why wait wait was aimed at me II know oh
I was aimed at you anyway
yeah that sounds that's not fair it
sounds fair really hang on run away
okay Harris oh way oh go nuts isn't get
on - hubba-wha cutter Bob if you're know
ha
didn't tell it that didn't work closed
closed though I thought it was gonna
work but it oh I I know what the problem
was okay I know what the problem was I I
know what the problem was
let's troubleshoot a little bit and I
got I got this I got this
hit I know what the issue was what is
the point of these dispensers they're
absolutely nice that one
Anabelle simple buh buh okay here we go
duck and cover Oh God
and in poop a little active TNT on the
side ah damn it
okay wait here's deal we'll team up
against a zombie in Latin cause there
know what they're doing here and we
don't I can't get them from here one
last idea it's got it's got to work
we'll like fires crooked well everyone's
a little different you know some people
are crooked some people are straight you
know it's like whatever I die judge this
is this is gonna work I'm fairly 90%
certain this is gonna work I need a I
need a redstone repeater hang on zombie
give me a chance give me one chance to
really blow up oh okay that's a really
elegant design but zombie
I need a redstone repeater give me one
chance to really show you what for there
we go Bob look out now oh my god bah oh
it didn't work at all damn it I had that
no keeps firing I don't know if I blew
my nup or they blew mine up I think
today a blue you're up cuz there I think
they blew your heart I just take a while
they're not gonna stop shooting mark why
not all my idea work my idea worked
Oh mark hurry up this is our chance
I'm trying what I do Bob sabotage place
the TNT where there button that they
were using to fire activated the TNT
yeah oh
not Latin sad after we've been begging
and pleading for to the one and only
shot mark I'm not I'm like ten minutes
from being done so are with me this made
them so mad they're gonna stir with the
[ __ ] out of it
I got it bear with me I've got the water
curtain protective defensive layer
that's what nettle is mmm yeah it's not
very you know but I like very strategic
if you know what I mean okay so it's
it's a water channel so the water here
okay and then with I've got okay three
you're gonna light okay skin cover ah
gotcha [ __ ] that's the most struck son
of a [ __ ] I say um I need one more
revision I know what I know what the
problem was I think I don't know what
the problem was no I think really gosh
darn it my tits he doesn't go far enough
eight mark they've already pre built
their cannon I'm just gonna go back to
shooting wages that was what worked so
I'm just saying will you be about stick
with that oh I know oh I know what I did
wrong I know what I did wrong oh well
I'm I have slightly deeper trench didn't
you yeah I had a deeper trench in the
center groove that's what it was I
forgot that that was a big part
well-well see if we could finish this
while they're totally blowing our [ __ ]
up completely but yeah well we got water
protection it's fine we got armor Oh
watch out mark watch out I'm okay don't
they're a bunch of babies what a bunch
of pansies they couldn't hit the
broadside of a my butt so yeah they're
they're definitely why is there a giant
hole in the ground that's what happened
when you shot our Kanan off life
oh my gosh that our last attack okay so
we devastated nothing at all to do with
me what oh come on
wait what is this nothing at all to do
with me
wait when you say things like that that
automatically makes me assume you had
everything to do with it
Oh oh my god why am I in the ground
zombie you cheater you read a baby's own
song I'm gonna die for this but you are
too what happened
I can't tell you're fine and you're not
damn it damn it old by mod powers what's
that thing
mmm-hmm is your cannon still exist Marco
do they destroy that - out of spite
I have no idea poor sportsmanship yeah
what about you sore losers over here hmm
oh my god but lose the sources yeah just
uh just a bunch of people that don't
care about stats fire I can and quickly
before we die again I'm not liking this
Wow okay ow Oh Cal we seem to be under
fire there mark mark we need to fire
right now it's ready it's Doug all right
okay all right whoa okay jeez man just
pressure me some more why don't you
alright it's loaded we have to fire
right now or we're totally hosed why
we're right now what was my oh jeez okay
all right I lit the back one and oh boy
oh boy run run run oh we did it
I didn't even reach their base shut up
and hit their water protection okay
so sup if you fire right now I'm in a
really bad place mark mark oh god I do
too I think we get a more narrow Wow
mark it's not a structural change I have
an idea that'll work out okay okay you
I'm gonna do it okay you do it I'm gonna
do it and oh no I'm here to help you
zombie because my house is disgrace to
mankind
mmm yes fire fire father I just
destroyed the kid and I'm sorry oh
my father would work oh I like how they
gave me a redstone repeater with no
intention of allowing me to use it
alright I trained them well it's gonna
accept my fate this is this is
absolutely pointless at this point no no
no no no no Bob
there's we're still in this fight I'm
not in it I have no chance man I got
nothing
Bob we're still maybe in this fight rip
me in the ass
she'll be in the app that's an odd thing
to shout Bob but I'm not gonna question
that's what's gonna happen so no okay I
got you I understand now
hey there it is I know I played it that
one oh you did that way well that's not
that is fun okay hang on okay not that
one okay I got it this is my last chance
to really show them what for okay here
we go
boom [ __ ] oh this is stupid as all
things gone maybe maybe like the problem
is that longer is not better I don't
know no whoa whoa whoa let's not be
hasty mark if you see what they're doing
yeah the point is not how long your
launch channel is its how many TNT you
can stack in one place for launching the
one that you want - OH
they're dropping four into one block
space
as their propulsion that's how they're
getting it distance on it oh that's what
I was trying to do when I totally [ __ ]
up your entire oh and you killed
yourself oh I guess that's why they got
the dispensers oh well if we had known
yes well
mmm I have I have a last ditch all of a
sudden my entire life makes sense
mmm wow thanks for getting it right in
my cannon thank you is that the point to
destroy you I don't know at this point I
don't know I don't think we've been
drinking enough this episode
no I haven't had time to drink I've been
too concentrating on this ardha look you
you drink some I'll take over for you no
no way I'm finally getting this down you
sure they add that's bad that's bad
that's bad oh that was so close
yep alright I figured it out guys I
figured it out you did I I mean I've
said this many times already but I
figured it out
it's gonna happen haha coming to watch
bob dole ready all right ready ready
no that's mistake that's I don't want to
plant my steak on the ground there we go
oh yeah ready wait yeah do it do it do
it do it do it do it do it
ha ha it all Soho's not that close but
you know close enough that it was
satisfying
you know they can't they can't penetrate
my invincible steel array of water bark
you got your water on my water ok and
your point is we need a fair dividing
one okay all right whatever fine you
have fun with your Everclear I'm gonna
build the greatest the balls cannon to
ever grace the world of cannon hood
are you sure two cannons hi that's
unfair yeah that's fair you all suck the
soup
I'm gonna blow you up if it's the last
thing I do but probably will be my last
thing you do yeah might be the last
thing I do actually I don't know that
you're gonna get close enough to blow
them up
no no no not in in in it I don't need to
be close and I need to be close I can be
as far away whoops I [ __ ] up I need a
pickaxe cuz I just put this in the wrong
place uh-huh uh-huh
pickaxe thank you thank you thank you
thank you you're welcome how do I point
this in the right direction okay all
right got it
I'm sure pretty sure down weight is
dominating but you aimed that at me
what all you're aiming in the hole I see
nevermind yeah yeah yeah what the
pickaxe again come back Wade we're all
on Team Wade royalty there you go I'm
thinking I'm thinking and I'm bill I
think you picked the wrong team to ally
with uh why I only ever got within like
three blocks of hitting your base ever
I'll jump these fire charges would you
like a fire charge no why would I want
your stinky stinky poopy fire eater now
let's add if I right-click your base
with it Oh
Oh lights on fire pickaxe I [ __ ] up
again how which wine blend the middle
here the weird one no not that one why
why'd you said the middle one what's
floating in the middle you [ __ ] oh that
one are you [ __ ] [ __ ]
he'll get off my team Oh God get the
[ __ ] pigs back oh okay you yell at me
they ask for my help
well you're if you weren't so stupid I
wouldn't have to need your help because
you screwed everything up anyway
ouch I'm gonna get revenge for you Bob
as soon as I can
I don't care anymore hey I'm not even
trying to well the goal okay that's
that's just rude what what just happened
work I am angry that's what's happening
shits about to go down
every say yes you're awesome can we turn
all green wool into TNT
no shut up let me do this if you don't
let me do this drug minecraft is
officially over you got that you got
that no ha ha
no more ho hee ha ha drink more huh what
do you try to do mark hey on just hold
your goddamn horses I'm gonna do this
you're gonna love it
it's good idea everything she's not
gonna work then shut up it's gonna be
fine just go nuts then it's gonna be
fine
do you need anything oh okay how do I
put a running on a dispenser I got it
there we go I'll have you're in the way
of the dispense Hogan I need your help
shush wait Oh what oh okay I'm
definitely not in the way of the cannon
mark don't worry hang on I need a I need
a well be gonna be responsible for
breaking mark dad see you Bob I could
see her name tag Bob do you think this
is gonna cause the cannon to break that
is amazing
look it's pretty close to what I was
saying
she's Busbee mark I think it into fire
soon you need to shut up yeah all the
time in the world my sir they're
compensating mark I'm pretty sure
they're ready to fire on your cannons
yeah whatever
my cannons are invincible actually that
our thing is working pretty well I know
cuz on the best come on can we fire the
can no not yet
we're not ready for some reason zombie
raised a white flag of surrender is that
a white flag of surrender you think he
did that before they just fired at us Oh
zombies what we gonna remember there's
two members on that team one of them
doesn't care mm-hmm was I always
remember that yeah
one loves to watch suffering it Mary
that's this really [ __ ] complicated
mark I know
Nico's here I'm awesome okay so here's
the deal all right okay I need a
redstone torch no wait I got a Kim
have none of those sorry can I can make
it I can make it you're gonna get owned
so hard get ready guys over there
ow here we go you ready you ready you
ready player huh and then oh my god mark
no that one actually hits their face
though good eye yeah look yeah oh [ __ ]
all the time I don't care about that but
I got you I got you I got ya
whoo I think everyone will understand
that we are the definitive winners uh
Bob and I am conquered or overcome many
obstacles but we recently so thank you
all so much for watching this experience
in drug minecraft we appreciate you
being here
thank you I'll be in Latin for being
gracious losers to us and uh check out
my channel and check out Vox Populi as
always we will see you go
oh why did it blow up they did all of
you had to have a channel on at least
three sides where the TNT doesn't fall
straight down and so the ones at the top
fell and hung up above the water and
blow everything up okay got him it got
it oh I got stopped come on I gotta stop
I'm a filler you three bull